jean pierre raffarin pour le groupe
union pour un mouvement populaire vous
avez la parole monsieur pour les
ministres merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre chers collègues je
rejoue voir bord du gouvernement en
harmonie c'est de vous saluer je
souhaite aussi que vous puissiez
transmettre la gravité de notre
sentiment à monsieur montebourg et à
toutes les autorités du gouvernement qui
ne sommes pas toujours donner le
sentiment d'avoir une conscience
suffisante de la grave crise et de
l'avis de tempête industriel qui est
aujourd'hui annoncé sur notre pays pour
l'année 2013 déjà les chiffres de 2012
quand on voit l'explosion des faillites
plus 40 2% de hausse des faillites sur
la fin de l'année aujourd'hui nous
allons vous en prie monsieur assouline
on vit pas avec ces choses là et je n'ai
pas d'esprit partisan dans tout cela je
sais qu'à des responsabilités partagées
sur l'histoire mais pensez à tous ses
salariés de l'automobile aujourd'hui qui
quand même nos groupes allaient bien
avait des difficultés et aujourd'hui que
nos groupes sont en grande difficulté
connaissent différentes inquiétude et
anxiété aujourd'hui moi je pense aux 700
salariés d'autoliv à côté de poitiers
aujourd'hui qui sont menacés je pense à
tous ceux des fonderies renault que nous
avons réussi à à sauver l'année dernière
et qui aujourd'hui sont extrêmement
préoccupés par l'état de la situation ça
c'est pas de la gauche c'est pas de la
droite c'est de la bataille comme le
disait le premier ministre contre le
chômage bataille première pour notre
pays respectez l'orientation qu'a été
prises par le pays tout ça pour vous
dire que dans cette situation
aujourd'hui nous sommes extrêmement
préoccupés
je voudrais vous dire que on comprend
bien que la ressource budgétaire
aujourd'hui elle fait pour aider les
entreprises c'est pas pour une raison
pour laquelle il faut faire des
ponctions mais il ya des mesures qui ne
coûtent rien et je voudrais vraiment
vous dire que il me semble que le
passage des seuils dans notre pays est
un sujet très grave le nombre
d'entreprises qui passent pas de 9 à 10
qui ne passe pas 49 à 50 qui se passe
passe de 149 à 150 il y a là des
blocages incroyants regardez le nombre
de pme aujourd'hui qui sont à 49 je
crois qu'il faut aider au franchissement
des seuils il faut réformer les seuils
dans notre pays il y alla de la
flexibilité de la compétitivité hors
coûts il y a là des possibilités de
développement qui sont donnés et ça on
ne peut prendre on ne peut pas prendre
l'argument financier pour refuser de
telles réformes je vous remercie merci
madame fleur pellerin
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs je crois que le
gouvernement est en tout entier
extrêmement conscient de la gravité de
la situation
actuelle si je crois tous et le
gouvernement sache et le être pleinement
mobilisé pour trouver des solutions à la
fois pour nos concitoyens qui souffre du
chômage ou la précarité mais aussi pour
les entreprises dont nous savons très
bien que la reprise la croissance et la
création d'emplois dépendent très
fortement alors je voudrais juste
insisté puisque vous parlez des seuils
de manière plus générale sur les mesures
que le gouvernement a prises pour venir
au soutien des pme nous avons lancé il
ya peu les assises de l'entrepreneuriat
dans le cadre desquelles beaucoup de
d'éléments extrêmement importants
soulevés par les entrepreneurs sont
examinés parmi lesquels effectivement un
certain nombre de verrous qu'ils soient
de nature réglementaire fiscale ou
autres qui bloque le développement la
croissance l'exportation de nos
entreprises où le financement de nos
projets entreprises en particulier les
pme alors sachez que dans le cadre de
cette réflexion il ya un groupe de
travail qui est consacrée à la
simplification la simplification
administrative notamment qui vise à
faciliter la vie quotidienne des
entreprises en limitant un certain
nombre de mesures en faisant en sorte
que les entreprises les pme notamment
soit conduite à ne produire qu'une seule
fois un certain nombre de documents
qu'aujourd'hui on a tendance à leur
demander de produire 5 6 7 10 fois dans
l'année donc c'était une mesure que nous
appelons dites le nous une seule fois
qui concourra justement à permettre aux
entreprises de se concentrer sur leurs
activités et non pas sur des démarches
administratives qui prennent du temps
coûte de l'argent et ne rapporte rien
aux entreprises et effectivement il ya
aussi une réflexion dans le cadre de ce
groupe de travail sur la simplification
sur la question des seuils qui est en
train d'être examinées parce que vous
l'avez raison c'est une problématique
qui est souvent soulevée mais que nous
avons du mal à étayer quantitativement
c'est à dire que l'impact
macroéconomique de cette problématique
des seuils n'est pour l'instant pas
suffisamment documenté donc nous
regardons avec les services sur lesquels
je m'appuie pour les entreprises 6 de
l'entrepreneuriat qu'elles sont en effet
les les blocages liés à ces sachant que
nous avons un certain nombre de contre
exemple je pense à une entreprise comme
criteo qui est aussi une entreprise du
numérique qu'une entreprise qui a connu
une croissance à deux chiffres au cours
des cinq dernières années et qui a
réussi à franchir ces plafonds de verre
donc nous travaillons aussi avec les
entreprises qui ont réussi à dépasser
ces problématiques pour voir de quelle
manière nous pouvons aider les autres à
suivre le même parcours mais sachez que
nous avons bien ces questions en tête eh
bien merci monsieur raffarin
merci madame la ministre de cette
question qui en partie correspond de
cette réponse qu'en partie correspond à
ma question mais elle je voudrais
simplement vous dire que ma conviction
c'est qu'il ya vraiment urgence sur ces
sujets depuis un certain nombre d'années
je suis élu je peux vous dire très
franchement tel depuis plus d'une
trentaine d'années je n'ai pas vu de
situation économique aussi tourmentée
que celle nous vivons actuellement c'est
simplement pour vous aider à mesurer
l'urgence de la situation
merci la parole est à présent monsieur
aymeri de montesquiou pour le groupe
union des démocrates et indépendants